no nobody knows and it was it was kind
of a new realize it was how big of a
deal was for me because I was I kind of
play it off they'll say no no it's fine
I'm gonna work from a chair and
different things but it really did kind
of mess a little bit with my my
confidence as far as you know my ability
to do some things I'm the daredevil I
love jumping off things jumping out of
planes or whatever and then well no but
but wait but wait so now so now this is
why she's laughing no I'm like kids now
be careful gonna hit your head there
look out should we jump from the injury
this has been his whole life he's like
well be careful be careful
we're like dared you're gonna make his
mess up because you're doing this that's
why she was laughing she wasn't laughing
because he like you know he's make this
turn in his life now he's so careful
he's always tiny little jump off and
yesterday we're supposed to do this as
like lean back he like sixes but yeah
because let's do a trust exercise right
now
true success turn around turn no no tell
me yeah fall back let's see if I see no
way come on let's do it